okay we're ready to start
uh sarah i am i'm just waiting
for a couple minutes just to make sure
that we
are actually live on youtube
before we um before we start so just
give me a couple minutes
absolutely all right
it's just so that our um comms team can
put the direct links to the meeting out
on social media
right good to go
yep good to go hello and uh welcome to
the executive colleagues nice to
uh see you all um apologies for absence
i think it's just um stephen purser
possibly isn't it
counselor purse is here so oh i should
have screamed that's wonderful thank you
nice to see you stephen
thank you i've seen nine people on my
screen i just flicked across thing
so thank you very much uh so no
apologies can i just say
at the beginning um although i don't
think we have any
uh counsellors have asked to speak
today's meeting just generally
uh in terms of being able to manage a
meeting uh i
would invite councillors who are not on
the executive just to give advanced
notice that they wish to attend and
speak
it just helps us in terms of the sort of
management and time
needed for the meeting so uh carrying on
with the
policy that gordon had applied
minutes of the meeting on the 21st of
july
our members content if you're not
content say
say so now otherwise we'll take you to
be content
anyone not content brilliant so we'll
take that as content then sarah thank
you
approved uh and any declarations of
interest or
anything interesting to declare
no that's so fine thank you very much uh
there are no public questions are there
sarah
no public questions no that's fine okay
so the executive forward plan is as uh
set out in the agenda we'll do a bit
more work on that over the next few
weeks but for today's meeting
our members well rather again is there
any
anyone has any comments about the
executive forward plan at the moment
okay fine okay right so let's move on
then
uh tony nice to see you tony mensah your
item six you're the
organizational recovery plan man
as it were many thanks uh alan so i'm
just gonna share
my screen now
so hopefully everybody can see that
okay so i'm going to provide you with an
update with regards to our
uh recovery planning arrangements and
the work that's been undertaken
uh so far and what work we have uh
upcoming
so in terms of our work undertaken um
we provided an overview of uh team
bridge's response to the pandemic to
date
to ons on the 14th of july
and at ons an agreement was made to
establish
working groups which i'll go into a bit
more detail about
later but to assess the impact
of covid19 on communities in teambridge
and also to review the council's
strategy
we conducted in july at officer level a
review of the t10
projects and performance indicators
that was completed by service leads to
really look at
what our priority should be what's kind
of viable in the short term given our
financial constraints
our recovery framework was established
and agreed
project leads and teams to put in place
and project framework
documents were agreed for each steam
area our project
leads also determined their draft
objectives
identified key stakeholders and also the
reporting mechanisms
into senior leadership team and also
through
meetings with portfolio holders and
established members for each theme area
we've established a data and
intelligence cell
and devised a methodology for data
collection for community
impact assessments and we've put into
place a project plan which i can go into
a bit more detail on later i have
uh shared the project plan and the
specification for the data and
intelligence so that's made up
of a junior data analyst who's working
with us
whilst he between study for his
undergraduate and
his postgraduate so we'll have him up
until
october he's got a background in
economics and
data analytics we have someone seconded
from the housing department our strategy
officer three days a week
um i've been leading on the cell and
then we also have our
community projects officer who's working
with us
and can also support the work of the ons
group around community impact
we've also conducted an internal review
led by david eatson
of our response phase emergency planning
protocols
really around preparation and
organizational resilience
for a second wave a local lockdown and
also for
what um is deemed to potentially be a
challenging autumn in winter
as you'll be aware we've also provided
the ons group with some
qualitative survey questions to assess
community impact and those have also
been
shared with members in terms of the work
in hand we're continuing to identify
quick wins and funding opportunities
by service area so some examples of that
are
the future high street funds bid and our
bid
to the next steps accommodation program
to support rough sleepers
we'd like to support the establishment
of the ons task and finish group
obviously that's subject to
reorganization that will be on hand
to provide whatever assistance is deemed
necessary
and from our perspective the important
thing is for us to ensure
uh that we're aligned in terms of the
officer-led data gathering
and we avoid duplication one of the
things that some of our partner agencies
have fed back both to ourselves and to
colleagues at devon county council
is that they've been bombarded with
requests
for input for case studies for surveys
we want to make sure that they
you know we don't um cause too much
survey fatigue
um and one of the things that we're
working on as it stands at the moment is
um an audit of existing data sources
and the literature review so looking at
those reports that have been produced
both on a
kind of local regional and national
level
to identify what the impacts have been
thus far
looking at existing data sources so that
we can
create a data warehouse so that we
identify what the gaps are that need to
be filled
through the quantitative surveys so
those surveys which are going to be
quite
direct in the questions they ask and
also through some of the qualitative
work so the more
open-ended interviews and questions
we're also looking to establish
some workshop events and spotlight
reviews so
in terms of kind of the the schedule of
the data gathering what we're proposing
is for the next two weeks um we'll be
uh going through that audit of existing
data sources and literature
reviews then developing our quantitative
surveys
and then we'll be reviewing our initial
findings
and then establishing the quality of
questions for theme specific workshops
and spotlight reviews
in terms of the audit of data sources
literature reviews
uh and all of that officer-led work
we're very happy obviously to share that
with members
so that can help to direct the work with
their
communities in terms of determining the
impact of cobin 19.
moving forward we will obviously be on
hand to provide whatever support is
necessary
in terms of upcoming work i've touched
on the data collection
the purpose that was outlined at once on
the 14th of july of establishing the two
o and s
groups was really so that we could
receive
recommendations based on the insights
that had been
provided by the community in terms of
the correction
of some of our work around recovery and
our
formulation of recovery plans and
objectives
that work we suggested in terms of
community
impact assessment precedes the work of
reviewing the council strategy i think
we need to start with the data and
understanding the insights
then receive recommendations of how the
council strategy should be reviewed
that's to remind
members a question of whether it's still
fit for purpose
and what our objectives should be around
recovery where our resources should be
directed in terms of the engagement and
work with
stakeholders um we'd also be very happy
for
member representation on those groups so
we foresee there being two sets of
workshops
the first to allow us to
take that qualitative approach to some
of the data gathering whereby
we look at the data that we've already
received we work with stakeholders
to better understand what their
priorities are
uh over the next 12 months two years
and then help us to determine our
objectives by theme area
um so the second set of uh workshops
will be
around looking at those objectives and
seeing if they are
can fit for purpose and they're aligned
with the priorities of some of our
partner agencies
throughout that process um as has been
mentioned on a number of occasions we
need to
be mindful of what is going to be within
our remit of our financial constraints
um we don't want to be in a position
where we promise people the world or
where we give the wrong impression
through the questions that we're asking
so through the questions that i've
shared with
executive one of the things that we have
looked at
is what priorities there are for
organizations moving forward and we've
said
whilst our direct financial support is
likely to be very limited
we've provided some examples of how we
can help including providing advice
support and guidance
partnership working digital skills
skills and communication support
signposting to help information and
training and identifying potential
sources of funding we're going to be
asking
or we're asking members to ask their
communities what their priorities are
and support needed in the short term and
then in the long term also
but then also asking what opportunities
covid 19 has provided their
organizations with
in terms of our long-term goals
obviously uh
we are aiming towards the construction
of overarching and theme specific
recovery plans for team bridge
and also to complete a comprehensive
review of the council strategy
i know that previously members have
asked for concrete timelines
and i'm happy to put those in place but
they will be governed by the work
schedule of the ons
group or groups that are established
what we previously proposed was that the
ons group around community impact
came with a report and recommendations
in november
i appreciate there may be a slight delay
to that process
that's not necessarily a bad thing from
our perspective because
as i'll touch on in a moment some of the
work of the devon wide group is moving
fairly slowly they had a bit of a kind
of short hiatus over
august as people were on leave and it
was difficult for them to organize
meetings
um i'd say that we're kind of ahead of
the curve to a certain extent in terms
of our
approach to data gathering and where
we're at also in comparison with some of
the other district
authorities um but what
our intention is after the christmas
period to be in a position whereby we've
gathered the data
we've taken recommendations by ons in
terms of community impact
we'll then seek recommendations in terms
of the review of the council strategy
and in the new year we'll put our
recovery plans in place
obviously they will be kind of subject
to or be determined by
our financial positions so uh we will
know more
in the autumn period on that front
in terms of representation on debris
wide groups as a reminder myself and
neil blaney
attend the recovery coordination group
but as i've mentioned
hasn't really met in august but he's
resumed
um the meeting schedule and his meeting
every couple of weeks on a fortnightly
basis
neil also attends the economy sub group
a climate and environment subgroup is
attended by will elliott
um a data and impact group has been
established they've put
a basic methodology in place which is
very similar to methodology we're
using and is based on something called
the manchester
university alliance model so manchester
university has kind of been at the
forefront of developing
this community covid19 community impact
assessment model
that looks at separating
effects impacts and opportunities and
then
determining your objectives around
recovery based on short-term
uh transactional opportunities and then
long-term
transformational change again obviously
we are constrained by budgets
uh in terms of how far we can kind of
implement
interventions um the communities
subgroup there's community subgroup
which has been established by devon
county
as well so that's working with
the third sector organizations helping
to feed into the data subgroup
whereby they assess the impact on
communities of kobit 19
and then look at how we can improve
partnership working and build on some of
the opportunities that
that covid has provided for improved
enhanced partnership working
with third sector organizations
the devon and torbay health protection
board has really
kind of taken precedence as you probably
understand
in terms of looking at our local
outbreak management plan and putting in
uh place
what they call action cards and standard
operating procedures
in the event of a local outbreak or a
second wave to make sure that
all of the services both at a county and
district level
have those robust plans in place means
of
escalation where appropriate and that we
have the organizational resilience to be
able to deal with the local outbreak
we're also represented on the
homelessness and health
cell which feeds into the health
protection board
that homelessness and health cell has
been predominantly focused on supporting
rough sleepers through the pandemic
it's now looking at supporting families
who might be threatened with eviction
are means for districts to identify an
early
early stage most people who might be
experiencing financial hardship
have difficulty meeting their rental
liability
and ensuring that we've got the office
of resources in place to deal with that
but also
where necessary and it's not possible to
prevent homelessness
the right type of temporary
accommodation to prevent people going
into bread and breakfast then excuse me
bed and breakfast accommodation
okay so that concludes my presentation
but i'm very happy
to field any questions at all
thanks to that tony um and as soon as
you're able to sort of take that screen
away then i can see
uh who's um
wants to speak that's
sorry i'm having a little bit of
difficulty on this laptop with the
controls are there thank you ever so
much tony
that's a really helpful overview of
what's been going on and where we are
today
uh colleagues any any questions for tony
while he's with us
so tony i just oh sorry andrew andrew
mcgregor
thank you alan um just wanted to to
check with tony what what are what are
going to be the measures
of uh progress and success as as we
progress through this
um plan
if you like that you're working on
yeah so in terms of putting the actual
concrete plan
in place what we need to be doing is
putting kind of reportable
actions in the same way that we do
through our council strategy
and link it to t10 objectives well i
would just stress that we're not at that
stage at the moment we're at the stage
of understanding what the impacts are
aligning our kind of officer led data
gathering and insights
with that of the kind of member-led
approach
through ons and that's the same across
the piste in terms of
what's happening at devon level at the
other districts
no one's got concrete recovery plans in
place
aside from uh i would say the economy
subgroup
for devon but as neil blaney may be able
to speak on because he attends that
subgroup that was
largely drawing on uh work that that had
preceded the
kovid 19 pandemic but certainly
in terms of when a plan is in place so
after we've
completed all of the data gathering
understood the insights
worked with stakeholders to refine our
objectives and make sure that they're
aligned with their priorities
then we need to be putting in place
reportable actions that are reportable
through the usual mechanisms so through
spa
and then reviewed on a regular basis via
ph involvement and then will we go
through the methods
sorry will we get the metrics that
inform the the reportable actions
yes absolutely very happy to share them
when they're in place
thank you and and tony i know we all
know but can you just
explain what spy is for people who are
watching and may not know
oh yeah yeah sure sorry so uh spar is
the reporting mechanism that
officers use to report on their
performance indicators
and projects and detail any exceptions
whereby
performance indicators haven't been met
or projects have been delayed for any
reason
um on a quarterly basis brilliant thanks
a lot tony i had a question i want to
ask myself
i'm sorry obviously appreciate a lot of
the more detailed works going on
um in terms of the here and now
so over the period say between here and
christmas you know for example if if
there were
an employer that was uh laying off
people or if people found themselves
you know unemployed because their photos
ending and the firms are laying them off
what what's the here and now offer uh
that's available in cambridge to
to help people how do we ensure that
they
sort of able to maximize their income
getting all the benefits they're
entitled to
is there someone looking at you know
making sure that people are signposted
and help
now yeah absolutely so what we do
benefit from
uh is a contract that we had that was
already in place
with a financial advisory service that's
being used um
to to help people maximize their income
and ensure that they're accessing any
support available that's called
homemaker
and the route into that can be either
through
people um applying or coming through our
customer services
um portal or or contact through customer
services
if they're engaged with housing or if
they're applying for any of our benefits
through our revenue and benefits service
also obviously if they they're requiring
council tax support for example
um so they'll be able to signpost and
ensure that the benefits are maximized
but also signpost to any kind of
additional support
in terms of grant funding etc that might
be available
one of the things that we've benefited
from is
having that direct link for people who
are applying for our
covid19 hardship fund the details of
that are available on our website
having that kind of linked up approach
has been helpful because we've actually
been made aware
of a number of people who as well as
experiencing financial hardship are also
potentially faced with eviction and
they're then directly linked in with our
housing service so yep certainly and
there is any of support that's available
um is detailed on the website i think
that's a really helpful overview tony in
terms of all colleagues
understanding kind of what's available
now
because i know that obviously very many
people are worried and while we're doing
the planning
uh for the kind of you know medium and
longer term challenge i really
appreciate that
overview colleagues and any other
questions for tony before we
let him escape sorry go back to the work
that he's doing
anything there no all right well we're
going to say
thank you very much tony i really
appreciate it and you'll come back and
give us a further update probably later
on in the year would that be okay
absolutely no problem thank you very
much that's spot on the right answer
thank you very much tony so thank you
ever so much
all right let's move on to item seven
colleagues which is the
budget monitoring revenue and capital
and treasury management lending list
gosh that's a mouthful isn't it so we'll
move to richard keeling and then
if there's anything further richard
needs martin flitcroft our chief
financial officer
is available as well so richard
councillor keeling
thank you thank you leader um first can
i correct the agenda
on page 13 in recommendations it should
read
note the updated budgetary position
colleagues i would first like to thank
our chief financial officer
martin flincroft and his team for
providing the updated budget
in these times of uncertainty the
finance team
have also stepped up to support work on
delivering the business grants
which have helped so many businesses
over the past months
unfortunately the government have been
slow to react to understand our losses
and this was evident in the first
tranche of funding being only
59 000 pounds it was only after martin's
team
explained to the ministry of housing
communities and local government
month after month painting the picture
of the importance of tourism
in our communities and our losses mainly
in our income streams
of car parking and leisure centers
a second tranche of 1.342
million has been forthcoming the
h the mh clg
from the mhclg meanwhile our finance
team have come up with a savings program
which would deliver approximately 2.1
million
these are savings from a freeze on our
capital projects
this leaves us still with a 5.8 million
in losses further funding is expected
from the government
as a fine as the finance team send
monthly reports
we have further uncertainty after the
new homes bonus finishes
and what will replace it again we wait
for government to inform us
i now hand you over to the chief finance
officer to go through
his report and any questions
leader i would like to come back at the
end to summarize
martin please thank you
um can you hear me
can you hear me yes martin good
we can hear you martin but it's clearly
very foggy where you where you are yeah
i i blipped out so for some reason the
picture's not come back but um
i'll take you through the report um so
this latest financial report is to
update members on the
budgetary position approve the updated
capital program appendix one
and note the updated lending list at
appendix 2.
section 2 of the report provides some
background to how we report financial
variations
and the large income streams have been
hit as a result of covid19
section three of the report identifies
the funding we have received to date
from government
in particular the latest funding is an
income funding package
to help with losses from sales fees and
charges
um and other sources of income that are
covered within the definitions
we're working through the detail and our
ledger line by line to determine what
this will provide
us with we have to bear the first five
percent of losses
and government will provide 75 percent
of the remaining 95
in section 4 we identified the net
budget deficit
at around 5.8 million this is after
identification of 2 million
pounds worth of savings to help with
that budget gap
the losses from council tax and business
rates can be recovered over the next
three years
so it's hoped that the income support
package will cover the remaining deficit
we will continue to monitor the position
week by week and any changes required to
any of our bad debt provisions
there may be some use of general
reserves to balance the books this year
but hopefully this will be minimal
section five of the report looks at
future years and the considerable
uncertainty that faces us
in particular understanding how the
economy will alter
impacts on businesses as the further
scheme ends
any further rises is unemployment and
other local lockdowns that may occur
in the months to come what government
support would be available next year
that's the biggest clarity we need um
sorting out we don't know these schemes
are for this year and for this year only
but we have no
future idea as to what will become
available for next year
um and we will continue to investigate
into making savings
as we know there will be deficits in
next year with our income streams like
to be lower than the pre-kerbit levels
we're also putting a report together to
come to full council on the 30th
september
30th september this year to align the
budget for this year
and section 6 of the report touches on
the latest treasury management position
and highlights the likelihood of being
in a boring position from october
depending on income streams there is
also some summary detail on the capital
programme projects in each service area
with the updated numbers in appendix 1.
so
in summary the major risks are in
relation to our income losses
government support for this and in
particular future funding
um that will come from government um and
will be part of the provisional
settlement
likely in december um that's the report
in summary um as i mentioned we're
looking to realign the budget in
september
at the end of september and that report
will be coming to full council
thank you thank you for that martin
that's really helpful if um if
colleagues who are
members of public are watching on
youtube if you haven't yet had the
opportunity to read that finance report
it really is worth the read because it
does set out a lot of detail about
the council's financial position the
impact of covid on the local authority
uh the losses that have been incurred
through um you know lost
drops in car park income because the
leisure centres have been closed
because of some of the commercial rents
that we receive all of these things
support the council services and what we
do so the impacts are very serious for
us
and as motto flitcraft identified
some of the losses can be carried
forward
over the next three years with regards
for example to council tax
i think that's a very important uh thing
to note so
at the moment i'm very content that we
are uh
preparing and coming back to council at
the end of the month with
a more detailed budget which revised you
know our
expectations and what it is we're able
to do so there's quite a bit of work to
be done in the next few weeks isn't
there and
uh the report before all colleagues
today i think is very helpful
explanation of the background where we
are and the task
that faces us all it's quite quite a
significant
uh amount of money to be found
especially if the government don't
meet all of what we thought they were
going to meet
so i think one of the issues we have
picked up is that you know team which is
one of the first local authorities to
apply for furlough funding and it now
looks as though the government might be
discounting that money uh from its
general support grant to us so
you know it's been one in one place
but looks like the government might be
trying to recover it somewhere else and
that's not particularly helpful
in terms of supporting the range of
public services that we deliver
anyway colleagues enough from me any
questions to either
counselor keeling or martin clickcroft
okay everyone seems rather content
richard we're going to come back to you
for
a final few words yes thank you leader
um
colleagues i would like to reiterate
these
are and will be difficult times we did
not want to make savings of 2 million
pounds
we did not want to freeze the capital
expenditure
but what we will do is balance the
budget
colleagues further details will be
shared on full council
on the 30th of september and i would
like you to please note
the updated budgetary position approve
the updated capital program
as shown in apex 1 and to note the
updated lending list
as shown in abix 2. thank you colleagues
all right
and second nuts yeah thank you
uh alastair and um again
just for ease does anyone dissent are we
all agreed
i'm taking no dissent so in that case
then we're all agreed sarah for the
record thank you very much thank you
uh so we'll move to i to make which is
the devon district's procurement
strategy
and again richard i i think that's you
counselor thank you leader yeah
thank you again i would like to thank
our corporate
procurement officer rosie wilson who's
here today
for her report the devon district
procurement authorities of mid devon
district council
north devon district council south ham's
district council torres district council
and west devon borough council
alongside team bridge have been working
together to draft and sign up to
the four key themes we have simplified
these to
keep local sustainability and
commercialization
we are monitoring outcomes and have hit
the targets for this past year
culminating in a minimum of 50 percent
in a devon wide spend we can do more
and we will i now hand you over to rosie
who will give you a presentation
and any questions again leader if i can
come back at the end
thank you
oh i hope helps if i unmute myself
doesn't it
rosie rosie wasn't procurement officer
and you're going to speak to the paper
nice to see you welcome
nice to see you all thank you very much
for your time this morning um
so i'm just going to share my screen
hopefully
um
um sarah it doesn't seem to be working
on my side is there any way you could
share the slide that i sent to you
i haven't got it on my laptop that i've
got on this one now
okay that's fine that's fine you are you
are a co-host so you should just be able
to press share
screen from the bottom
don't worry let's not torture ourselves
oh there we go there we go
there we go i i just very quickly had to
um
rearrange my security settings right
okay done um
so this is just to echo what
counselor keeling has said um and
the background is that it's a review and
reform of the
2014-2018 strategy
it's a collaborative strategy and you
can see all the authorities that are
included in there
you might be wondering why east devon
isn't included east devon's procurement
is actually run by
devon county council with the
2014 to 2018 strategy there were
three key outcomes that we wanted to
improve on
these were contract management
sustainable procurement
and engagement with smes with regards to
contract management
we want to be seen to
continue our relationship with the
suppliers throughout the contract
with the sustainable procurement this
isn't just about environmental
sustainability it's about social value
equality and diversity
to fulfill our corporate social
responsibility and thirdly
with regards to engagement with smes we
want to keep
and we want to actually improve on
central government's targets of 33
and we are on target for that
with regards to the action plan um
there are four key elements so from from
the key outcomes contract management
sustainable procurement engagement with
smes
but we've also added an extra element
which is behaving commercially
this is mainly due to the fact that it's
not just about saving money but
revenue generation as well we need to
try
and close that budget gap during these
post covert 19 times and
i've just summarized in the bottom right
hand corner the main changes
um from the
devon wide strategy compared to the team
bridge strategy
because there were some elements where
you know
there were some quick wins that we could
do now and these are mainly
to ensure that officers are considering
local suppliers in the first instance
for spend that is ten thousand pounds
and under and this has been added to the
strategy for
team bridge uh this has also been added
to the strategy for south hams and west
devon
as i represent those councils as well
the second uh change is that the fact
that we
have a target of 50 devon wide spend
and the recommendation to the executive
is to adopt this devon wide
procurement strategy and it will be
reviewed on an ongoing basis
i'm now going to stop sharing and i will
welcome any questions from the executive
thank you stephen councillor person
uh thank you and thanks for that
presentation um
in view of the this to me is such a very
good idea
are the long-standing historical reasons
why
devon plymouth and torbay are not
included in it because
clearly with that spend combined one
would think we would
all be in a very very strong position to
no negotiate
you know very substantial deals and
discounts uh within devon but it
i don't know the background it might be
some long-standing historical reasons
yes absolutely um prior to kobit 19
um the unitary councils
um were collaborative
but not to this level um post covert 19
we are actually forming a working group
with devon county tour bay council
plymouth city council
to look at ways we can collaborate get
those economies of scale
and influence the local spend
and that is happening and again we want
to
make changes as quickly as possible and
but this will be
a long process in the fact that we need
to create the group
get the collaboration there um and and
then start seeing the changes
fine thank you thank you for that and
we'll just hold that thought about how
long
this is going to take i'll come back to
at the moment uh councillor dewhurst
thank you leader um rosie thank you for
for your report and thank you for the
uh answers to the questions i i sent you
on it um our target specifically for
team bridge
is quite low and i just wanted to know
really what
what we're doing to try and increase
that that target
of of our our council spend team bridge
council spend
here in team bridge please okay um
so just for everybody else uh the the
team bridge target is 15
this is reflective of preston city
council
and and for those who are aware of the
preston model
this is the model that we are
benchmarking towards
um in terms of community wealth building
and
keeping spend locally so that it doesn't
leak out of the economy
the devon economy um so we are on track
for 15
i i believe that nine uh financial year
1920
was 14.7
so we are on track for that and yes i
completely agree with you it can be
improved
but i think that by doing the
quick wins of getting officers to
consider
team bridge suppliers for in the first
instance for 10 000 pounds
and under um that will really help us
and then we can review it on an ongoing
basis with the other authorities about
what we can do
to get this better and better obviously
it is difficult in team bridge we you
know we
we we're we're we have we have moors we
have
we have the seaside we have towns but we
are still quite rural in the fact that
compared to a london authority they've
they've probably got a lot more of a
supply base
but we can we can get there um it's just
we we just need to ensure that officers
know what to do
and also ensure that suppliers are
being engaged as well so one of the
plans that i have
working under the vital viable council
task force is to create
more virtual meet the buyer events with
local team bridge suppliers so that they
know
how how to bid
or how to quote or you know trying to
make the process
as easy as possible for them
fantastic thank you that that last
little bit
sort of concerns me a bit because if
we're talking about sums of money
uh under 10 000 pounds what one would
hope it would be pretty simple
to bid for for for work uh
for our council and uh one would hope so
uh and and what kind of barriers that
there might be
uh to stopping people bidding absolutely
um
under 10 000 pounds it it will it will
be pretty simple
it would just be a case of uh an officer
would go out to three
suppliers three to five suppliers with
an email saying could you please give me
a quote for this
um and you're you've still got to prove
that you're getting your best value for
money not
not necessarily the cheapest but the
best value um
with regards to our contract procedure
rules which are going to be reviewed
in december um
the threshold for a formal request for
quotation
is seven and a half thousand uh so
anything above that
would have to be a formal request for
quotation via our procurement portal
and this is the area that i want to help
out those local
suppliers who who may not know about the
portal
and and then
once we've reviewed the thresholds and
if if they were to increase that will
then
help other local suppliers
and but that's that's what we're doing
at the moment
from talking to suppliers at the
regenerate devon event
their their main concern was that the
procurement process
was difficult and so now it's my aim to
make it
easier for them fantastic more power to
your elbow
thank you rosie thank you abso
absolutely thank you for that rose i'm
going to come to
council wrigley in a moment but um for
me
it's what you're saying about ironing
out the bumps in the procurement process
about making it easier
for me we can't get this work done soon
enough uh because
um one of the responses to kovid19 is
about
the council spending more of what it's
got within its district
absolutely and every day it takes longer
to do that than we might otherwise do it
as a day delayed in responding so you
know my view is as probably one of the
biggest
spenders uh in the district not the
biggest
whereas one of the biggest you know it's
our job to lead by example
so uh i'm thrilled to bits you know you
say rosie we're at 14.7
in the last financial year um and i just
need to say you know we mustn't rest on
our laurels if we
if we tickle it around 15 we should be
striving for
20 25 whatever it might be and just
absolutely busting the barrier on this
and not just saying
we've made 15. i don't know that was
anyone's intention rose i'm not
suggesting it is but
you know sometimes we get to a target
that we've imposed on ourselves
and say well we've hit that and we
really need to be saying
no that really is the baseline we need
to bust it and bust it well
uh really and we need to be speaking as
you're saying to these small businesses
about
what we can do to help them and what
they can do to help themselves like
i do remember that there was one issue
particularly a small family wanted to
use but
the council had a particularly um a
threshold on public liability insurance
but a lot of small businesses
don't ensure at the level and that that
became a barrier
um but when you looked at the job the
level of insurance
the council wanted was probably quite
high i know why we've got it as a
standard
and i think sometimes it's really
understanding that level of business
isn't it if you are
a particularly small trader it may be
that you don't perceive that you need a
bigger level
anyway i've rattled off for long enough
uh martin councillor wrigley
uh thank you leader well you you rather
taking one of my questions away because
i was going to ask about that very
question about
small businesses and uh insurance levels
and reviewing that our
requirements which do often put small
businesses off
are in fact uh reasonable and and
appropriate
and that we explain those reasons why
but um thank you rosie for uh doing all
this and it's good to get all of the
larger
um councils together for uh purchasing
power as uh councillor person was saying
that seems
an eminently sensible thing and to make
the process easier for the smaller
businesses
um so in addition to the question about
insurances i was going to ask about
the environmental and carbon
uh standards that we were talking about
six or nine
months ago um i didn't see mention of
those could you enlighten us as to
what's happened with those
please um so we are
we are currently working with officers
to
make their tenders specifically
um section their tenders out so it's
quality price
and sustainable procurement um officers
have been doing that
and i will be i'm hoping to
come to the executive with um a report
with how many tenders we have put out
there
which have included sustainable
procurement um
and how much we have measured that by i
don't have anything
to show you right now but that will be
coming in the future
and from what i've seen
we are already improving and i'm working
with william elliott at the moment
um we are working together on the
sustainable procurement policy
because um there are aspects in there
that he can add to to make it
better excellent thank you
thank you martin thank you rosie any
other questions from colleagues
yeah i was waving my hand badly there uh
i i was looking i was looking for an
electronic hand up but never mind thank
you very much my apologies
no don't worry andrew um it was just
um a couple of quick questions and and
some of them have already been answered
um do we factor into the value for money
um
aspect the the fact that they are based
locally and we will get
you know sustaining business within the
team bridge district and wider devon
context
gives us a better opportunity to recoup
some of the money back in through
business
uh business rates or and or council tax
um
and and and also ten thousand pounds
seems
you know a fairly low amount of money is
it worth perhaps considering moving that
up
the goal posts to twenty thousand which
would then push us
more quickly perhaps towards hitting the
15
and then pushing beyond because i what
i'd quite like to do is
not to have preston as the standout
example i'd quite like team bridge to be
the standout example
of how it's done and how it's done well
um
and then another perhaps interesting one
is quite often there is a
um excuse about the dog barking in the
background something at the door
um the i think
i think when we look at sort of wider
large companies
that we use um
excuse me i'm going to switch off the
dog is annoying me and it's please
i i think i can answer some of um your
questions so
with regards to uh the 10 going up to 20
absolutely you know this is this is why
we will review it on an ongoing basis
and
and and if we feel that yes we we can we
can boost that then then
certainly we will with regards to um
adding something into the tender to say
that we
will uh you know only buy locally and
you'll get more points if you're local
it's it's a fine line and once you get
into this tender territory
because then you start to talk about
reverse discrimination
um because the eu treaty principles
within procurement are
fairness transparency i should know the
rest but
that's along the lines of of what they
are and
and if you start talking about um
favoring suppliers who are local then
you get into the territory of reverse
discrimination which could
result in a challenge so it's my job to
try and
engineer the tender so that
it will benefit local suppliers but
without
any form of challenge so for example if
we were having a
repair and maintenance for our fleet
we we want local so and we can justify
that
um and it's it's just our job to try and
bend the rules without breaking them
um so so if i come in though i think
that the
for me the issue is
our goal is to get more spend locally
i understand entirely what it's staying
with i i don't really see it as bending
rules but it's about shaping the rules
that achieve the outcomes the council
wants it's about supporting local
businesses
but equally there may well it's not
about supporting local business
at the cost of everything else so
where they offer the best value it may
not be the cheapest price but the best
value
we will go with them but in fairness
there may be a supply from out of county
out of district which is you know
it's got what we need and want and you
know they are the best
on that you know and it can't it has to
be
a moderated approach but the for me the
overall emphasis is
uh let's support trading team which
trade in devon
and if it has to be outside of devon
then it has to be but
you know it's i think what you're saying
rosie is that we have to work within the
rules
and and shape them to achieve what
others are doing it clearly they are
and you know i think that's andrea's
point as well and i think for me
uh whether it's ten or twenty thousand
we might move to twenty thousand quite
quickly
um i think for me the stepped approach
is
is fine we just need to get more of our
money spent locally
uh as quickly as possible
nina council jeffries
hello thank you um thank you rosie i
think it's a really interesting
piece of work um i just wanted to add a
couple of things
um nothing any different anybody else
has said i don't think but um
i think the piece of work is definitely
needed especially for smaller suppliers
um i know the national planning policy
framework has
made some changes recently which this
will fit in nicely with
um but there's also the encouragement
from the lga
the local government association for
those listening in that might not know
what that is
um of 20 minute neighborhoods so this
really fits in with that and how the
changes of um from covid will be
going forward um and supporting local
supplies and procurement so thank you i
just wanted to say so
i'll look forward to um looking at the
changes
all right uh any other questions or
points
um what we've learned today is that we
need to procure bonyos for council
mcgregor's goal
that's the answer isn't it um all right
so colleagues
uh richard we were going to come back to
you for a final summation thank you
recommendations yeah and can i say my
newfoundland is very quiet by my legs
here
um i hope to get through this without a
pheasant going past or
or something like that um we're
listening colleagues we're listening to
what you're saying now
and and we understand that you know you
want to move forward with this
we can do better and we will um
colleagues
the committee recommends to executive
that the themes actions and outcomes
set out in the devon district
procurement strategy 2019-2022
are approved and to establish
any council specific priorities or
objectives
which need to be incorporated into the
strategy jointly or individually
thank you brilliant thank you for that
andrew thank you richard uh again
um any members not content with that um
okay so we're going to take that as
content and approved
thank you very much for that thank you
richard thank you rosie greatly
appreciated
and we'll move to item nine which is the
recommendation from overview and
scrutiny committee performance
monitoring reports now
hopefully all colleagues have had a
chance to read that and it's a proposal
from overwhelming scrutiny the committee
on the way it wished uh executive
members to report to them
and present um
obviously uh there will now be two of
you in scrutinies but uh
i'm very keen that we don't get endless
debate about process and we we get on
with the job
uh so might i suggest to colleagues that
we accept the recommendations
uh and it's a working model that i think
will work for two overview scrutinies as
one
um and and we work with our colleagues
and
let's get cracking so i'm not gonna
spend further time on it
any comments from colleagues any
questions
martin i just say i i welcome it a lot
because the
input from the other members of overview
and scrutiny is extremely helpful when
you're looking at your portfolio
and that extra level of scrutiny is
helpful
in us doing better jobs so i think this
will be a good improvement
it is i'm glad scrutiny spent some time
looking at that and what worked for them
as well
and i think that's really helpful so
colleagues again any dissent
we're all content okay we're going to
mark that down as a content then sarah
is that okay
yes that's fine brilliant okay thank you
very much uh colleagues there's nothing
else on the agenda i'm reluctant to
detain you
longer than necessary i'm sure you've
got things to do if i need to go and put
the kettle on and make a well-earned cup
of coffee
and to give that dog a bonio in timmouth
so
with that thank you ever so much
colleagues and we'll see you in a
month's time
thank you
bye everyone hi everyone hi everyone
bye everyone
you